[Music]
the coronavirus pandemic is shutting the
stores in new york city
but the artists are moving in the bad
news can seem endless
but amidst the depression people are
trying to find solace
in art
[Music]
artist therapy not only for us but for
people seeing it
and i mean to see a vacant store is a
sad thing
but when you can you know you can
celebrate that space
with art it's so important it just it
changes your mood
and it also brings foot traffic to the
area it helps surrounding stores that
are struggling to make rent payments
it's a symbiosis of art and business
together
they're coping with bad news in a city
that desperately needs good news
especially now people are saying that
new york is dead and this and that
and it's not true you know we're still
here we're still fighting
and i think it's important to share that
the collaboration of landlords
businesses and artists in new york shows
how important it is to cling to positive
things
especially in times of crisis
hello and welcome to our coveted 19
special here on dw news
i'm monica jones good to have you with
us how do you feel today
well these days it's not easy to find
that silver lining on the horizon right
especially when you get bombarded with
bad news day in day out
it's time for the media to do better
india
added a record number of new coronavirus
cases on sunday
hundreds of elephants have been found
dead in recent months
being described as non-stop bad news is
the world really in such a thoroughly
terrible state
for countries in the region
of course the current coronavirus
pandemic is indeed an extraordinary
global crisis
but if you take a longer term view you
see there have been many positive trends
infant mortality has never been lower
[Music]
and the number of people killed in
natural disasters has been averaging
downwards
still we often get the impression things
are just getting worse and worse
myself included even though as a
journalist i don't just consume news
but also help shape it why are we more
sensitive to bad news
does it have something to do with the
brain i'm on my way to see
neuroscientist marin una
she has researched precisely these
questions
[Music]
the brain processes negative news faster
better and more intensively than
positive or neutral news
we also remember it better in terms of
evolutionary biology
processing negative information better
than positive information has been
helpful
because in the age of the saber-toothed
tiger and willie mammoth
missing a piece of bad news might well
mean that's it for you
studies have shown the test subjects
from different parts of the world
became more excited and alert as soon as
they were shown
bad news regardless of their location
and culture
many media outlets use this effect to
their advantage
negative headlines sell more copies and
get more clicks
[Music]
studies show that the media are
publishing more and more bad news
especially online
is this the new is it a problem if the
media revel in bad news
first and foremost it makes us all have
negative expectations
so we go through life with the world
view in which we assume the world is
worse than it really is
the impact of media reports can be
extremely strong
take the boston marathon bomb attack in
2013 for example
some people who followed the news
obsessively were more stressed and
frightened than others who had been
physically present
so what does this mean
first of all it makes people less likely
to take action
you might think the realization that we
all have a world view that's too
negative
would actually prompt people to become
more active but many psychological
studies have shown that that is
precisely not the case
what's more it can promote chronic
stress we know that chronic stress can
be a factor in many diseases
including diabetes cardiovascular
disease
and mental illnesses such as depression
the coronavirus pandemic is a good
example
after months of bad news many people
have grown weary of the crisis
they feel helpless and wish things would
go back to normal
[Applause]
as a journalist i have to consider
whether i might be contributing to other
people having a misguided view of the
world
what can the media do better
well that's the big question let's bring
in ulrich hagerup
founder and ceo of the constructive
institute journalism for tomorrow
in denmark good to have you with us how
do you cope with all the bad news
i try to see the world
and my news with both eyes both looking
for the problems but also for the
nuances
and and the hope the problem and the
weight forward
now not everybody is capable of doing it
and
we certainly learned that a bad news uh
sell
better than good news it seems in the
media then it's all down to profit
what could prompt media outlets to take
a different
approach here to understand that that is
a big misunderstanding the american
calls
that if it bleeds it leads it turns out
not to be true if you ask people
on the street in berlin or elsewhere in
the world do you need more news
do you need faster news they will most
likely say
no i'm drowning in it but i need
something
i i need something to trust i do need
journalism but i
need a need journalism that is
passionate but also
give me a full picture of of the world
that is what people want they want
not more information but they need
navigation
stories about where we are where we come
from
but especially moving ahead so the idea
that
it's only fear that we should tap into
it that we've been doing in the news
industry for years we're tapping people
on the shoulder there's breaking news
here something bad might happen here in
a falling tree in indonesia
everything is going to hell watch here
that has been our strategy
and it has turned out that people turn
their back on us
they are overwhelmed and they didn't
want to pay for it
so if we think about it we should know
and listen to psychologists who say yes
fear is very strong and as you said
it comes down from the stone age but
hope is bigger that's the reason why
people get up and immediately but we
still and we should remember that
absolutely but we still have to
obviously it's a journalist's job to
report the truth and the truth isn't
always beautiful
yes and sadly a lot of bad things happen
in the world so how can you as a
responsible journalist
strike the right balance reporting the
truth
but not adding to people's anxiety
yeah and and we should not we should not
give people false hope
we our job is not to put a smile on
people's faces we
are in the information that the trust
business and we should remember that
but we should we should see both the
problems and then we should take one
step further instead of just
just looking for another story and other
problem we can
tap people on the shoulder with it you
also have to watch this this could also
be dangerous
we should stick to the problem and ask
the constructive questions
pointing to the future asking now what
and how if we have a problem
what have other countries done that we
can learn from that
changes the conversation that changes
the perspective offer solutions
give people a helping hand and uh with
half a minute to go
is there anything positive in this
current crisis the pandemic
that we as journalists can take away
from
there there's a lot one of them for me
i don't have to spend two days going to
berlin to talk to you for five minutes
i could stay here we have learned more
and more to do that also
in in meeting in the in the business
world we have learned a lot of things in
denmark for instance we should know
and but people don't know that less
people
have died in denmark in 2020 than in the
last 10 years
every year why because people don't get
the clue
all right well that's that's in good
news indeed uh group their founder and
ceo of the constructive institute
journalism for tomorrow thank you so
much
you're welcome well time now for your
questions over to our science
correspondent derek williams
how are we supposed to deal with
coronavirus fatigue when restrictions
are being reimposed
this isn't a science question it's a
personal one
but pandemic fatigue is affecting so
many people
all over the world that i wanted to
spend a couple of minutes
sharing my own thoughts on it um here in
germany where it gets
dark and and cold in the winter a lot of
people
are really dreading the next few months
even though compared to many other
european countries things are
are actually going pretty well here so
far but it feels
like they're balanced on the edge of a
knife and and it wouldn't take much to
tip the scales and slide the country
into some some pretty dark territory so
for me at least
in addition to just being heartily sick
of pandemic restrictions there's also
an underlying layer of fear that never
really goes away and and getting through
the next few months
will be easier if i can lessen it
what helps me personally keep my fear
somewhat at bay is is is focusing
on the science which is not to say that
it provides
crystal clear answers all the time
science is messy and
what it seems to be saying can often
change over time
just look at what it now says about mask
wearing for example compared to
to a year ago but the fact that ideas
can change
based on new evidence is not a weakness
it's it's
actually science's great strength and
look at how far it's brought us
less than a year after the first
reported cases of this sometimes
deadly fast spreading disease what we've
learned about treating it has steadily
lowered fatality rates
among those who catch it and and there's
a good possibility we'll see
large-scale vaccination against covet 19
next year that's amazing because it
shows
we aren't helpless even if we are afraid
and exhausted by the whole pandemic
thing
i at least am now hopeful that if we can
only hold out
for a few more months things will look
different in 2021.
in a nutshell i battle my own pandemic
fatigue by
reminding myself of how far we've
already come
and with hope for where i think we're
going to be
in the not too distant future
you